histoire de ne pas vous saouler avec ça
si vous êtes abonnés à la chaîne j'ai un
petit message pour vous à la fin de la
vidéo après là haute trop saluer
bienvenue à l'explication de la semaine
oui le dimanche je vous apprends quelque
chose pour bluffer les autres et
aujourd'hui on va parler dessous parce
que tout le monde est intéressé par
l'argent tout de suite les gens sont
beaucoup plus attentifs sur un tour où
il ya un peu de pognon vous demander à
quelqu'un de sortir une pièce de deux
euros 2 1 euros et de 50 centimes
d'euros si vous n'avez pas de pièces
avec vous si vous avez pas ces valeurs
vous pouvez aussi prendre trois petits
papiers puis marqué 2 euros 1 euro 50
centimes d'euros voulait placer devant
la personne pour que de sa gauche
à sa droite y ait 2 euros 1 euro et 50
centimes d'euro d'ailleurs si vous
voulez vous pouvez le faire maintenant
que moi sur la vidéo mais attention ce
n'est pas une mise au défi puisque après
je vous l'expliquais vous demandez à
votre ami de mélanger les trois pièces
dans l'ordre qu'il veut de les placer
dans l'or qu'il veut sauf dans lord au
départ de 1 50 centimes
donc il est mélangé il le met dans un
ordre complètement aléatoire sauf lors
de 1 50 centimes qui est l'ordre de
départ si vous êtes en train de faire le
tour en même temps que je l'expliquais
faite le ensuite vous demandez à votre
ami dé changer la pièce de deux euros
contre la pièce qui est directement à la
droite de cette pièce là et s'il n'y a
pas de pièces à droite alors ils ne
touchent rien encore une fois si vous
êtes en train de faire le tour en live
faite le et sinon votre ami vous
prévient qu'il a terminé de le faire
ensuite demandé lui d'échanger sa pièce
de 50 centimes contre la pièce qui est
juste à sa gauche à la gauche de la
pièce de 50 centimes sauf s'il ya pas de
pièces évidemment et pour terminer il
doit échanger la pièce de 1 euro contre
la pièce qui est directement à sa droite
sauf s'il n'y a pas de pièces vous avez
compris et là vous vous concentrez et
vous pouvez révélé que les pièces sont
de la gauche vers sa droite dans l'ordre
suivant 50 centimes 2 euros et 1 euro
si vous l'avez fait c'est ce que vous
avez devant les yeux là actuellement
vous avez bien compris que le
fonctionnement c'est une logique de
mentalist un raisonnement mathématique
il suffit donc de suivre les cinq étapes
mais dedans le premier ordre de départ
50 centimes 1 et 2 et ça vous donnera
cet ordre-là obligatoirement s'il n'y a
pas le choix c'est purement mathématique
comme raisonnement donc si vous l'avez
fait en même temps que la vidéo et que
vous n'avez pas obtenu ce résultat là
c'est que vous vous êtes trompés ou que
vous avez volontairement pas suivi les
consignes vous pouvez également
l'adapter à plein de choses différentes
par exemple si vous êtes dans un bar
vous fait poser des objets aléatoire un
téléphone portable un briquet etc vous
retrouverez le placement finale vous
pouvez aussi en terme de représentation
faire semblant de capter les choses
comme sa distance
vous pouvez également écrire l'ordre à
l'avance comme une prédiction ou comme
une
fluence l'intérêt d'un tour
arraisonnement automatique comme celui
ci c'est que vous pouvez construire une
vraie histoire une vraie mise en scène
un vrai délire dessus faites-le puisque
vous n'avez pas de temps à passer dans
la compréhension de l'effet ou dans
l'entraînement alors prenez le temps de
faire quelque chose de sympa et ne
gardez pas forcément juste les pièces
comme ça mettez-y un enjeu quelque chose
de plus intéressant que de le faire pour
le faire j'espère que vous allez vous
éclater avec ce tour que vous allez
faire dès aujourd'hui où toute cette
semaine en bluffant tout le monde si
cette vidéo vous a plu n'oubliez pas de
me le faire savoir en laissant un petit
pouce en l'air vous pouvez également
laisser un commentaire au bas de la
vidéo vous avez vu hier j'ai répondu à
tous les commentaires de la semaine en
tout cas je les ai tous lus et j'ai
répondu un maximum d'entre eux merci
d'être là passer un excellent dimanche
et rendez vous demain à 17 heures parce
qu'on sera lundi donc demain à 17 heures
je vous ferai un petit blog sur ouche
habite et où je vis n'oubliez pas
également de vous abonner avant de
partir à demain ciao
vous le disais au début de la vidéo
petit message très rapide donc pour ceux
que ça intéresse c'est pour ça que je
vais pas le mettre en plein coeur de la
vidéo parce que c'est pas forcément
intéressant pour tout le monde il ya
quelques semaines j'avais bloqué des
images aux secrets de studio d'ailleurs
j'avais perdu une partie des rushes du
coup y'a pas grand chose j'étais assez
dégoûté mais j'avais sorti la vidéo
parce qu'il fallait bien je sorte le
principe c'est que j'allais faire une
conférence dans un lieu secret sur le
mentalisme cette conférence est
aujourd'hui en ligne sur le site de
secret studio depuis le 26 mai je crois
qu'elle est en ligne
elle dure plus de deux heures où je
parle durant deux heures de mentalisme
des faits de choses à faire avec de
chose que j'espère bluffante à faire
avec
ils sont forcément un petit peu plus
poussée que sur la chaîne puisque là
j'avais quand même deux heures devant
moi pour parler vous avez été
quelques-uns une petite dizaine un pas
nombreux à me demander dans les
commentaires ou est-ce qu'on pouvait
trouver la conférence etc
c'est vrai qu'au départ je comptais pas
en faire la pub je n'avais pas mis de
lien à l'époque dans le descriptif et
tout donc je vous mets le lien dans le
descriptif de cette vidéo là et comme ça
si ça vous intéresse vous pouvez aller
voir et puis n'hésitez pas à me faire un
petit retour là-dessus passé un bon
dimanche ciao